hi guys
so today's session is on aws age maker
but before proceeding with this topic i
would request you guys to like our video
also subscribe to our channel you can
find the link just below at the right
side of this video
let's look into what we have in our
today's session so what's in it for you
we would be covering what is aws why do
we need
aws sage maker what is aws
sage maker services what are the
benefits of using the aws sagemaker
machine learning with aws sagemaker how
to train a model
with aws stage maker how to validate a
model with aws and the companies that
are using
aws stage maker along with that we will
be covering up
one live demo on the aws platform
now let's understand what is aws so
what is aws it's an amazon web services
it's a largest
or most widely used public cloud
platform
offered by amazon it provides services
over the internet
aws services can be used to build
monitor
and deploy any type of application in
the cloud aws
also uses the subscription pricing model
that means you only pay for whatever the
services you
use for now why do we need aws sage
maker let's look into it
so let's consider an example of one of
the company that is
proquest now before aws sagemaker
the proquest is a global information
content and technology company
that provides valuable content such as
ebooks newspapers etc to the users
before aws sh maker the proquest
requirement was
to have a better user experience maximum
relevant search results
now after aws sagemaker they were able
to achieve those
results so they achieved more appealing
video user experience
they achieved more relevant search
results for the users now
what do we mean by aws age maker why
this service is primarily used
so amazon sage maker is a cloud machine
learning platform
that helps users in building training
tuning and deploying
machine learning models in a production
ready hosted environment
so it's kind of a machine learning
service which is already hosted on the
aws platform
now what are the benefits of using aws
sagemaker
the key benefits of using aw sagemaker
are
it reduces machine learning data cost so
you can do the cost optimization while
running
this particular service on the aws all
ml components
are stored in a particular place in a
dashboard
so they can be managed together highly
scalable
so it can be scalable on you can scale
this particular service on the fly it
trains the models
quite faster maintains the uptime so
you can be assured that your workloads
will be running all the time it will be
available all the time high data
security so security becomes a major
concern on the cloud platforms
and it ensures that you have the high
data
security along with that you can do a
data transfer to different aws services
like s3 bucket and all
with these simple data transfer
techniques
now machine learning with aws sagemaker
let us look into it
so machine learning with aws sagemaker
is a
three-step function so one is to build
second is to test and tune the model and
third
is to deploy the model now with the
build it provides more than
15 widely used ml algorithms for
training purpose
now to build a model you can collect and
prepare training data
or you can select from the amazon s3
bucket also
choose and optimize the required
algorithm so some of the algorithms that
you can select
are k-means linear regressions logistic
regression
sagemaker helps developers to customize
ml instances
with the jupiter notebook interface
in the test and tune you have to set up
and manage the environment
for training so you would need some
sample data to train the model
so train and tune a model with the
amazon
sage maker sage maker implements hyper
parameter tuning
by adding a suitable combination of
algorithm parameters
also it divides the training data and
stores that in the
amazon s3 s3 is a simple storage service
which is primarily used for storing the
objects and the data
hence it is used for storing and
recovering data over the internet
and below you can see that aws sagemaker
uses amazon s3 to store data as it's
safe and secure
also it divides the training data and
stores in amazon s3 where the training
algorithm code is
stored in the ecr ecr stands for elastic
container registry which is primarily
used for containers and dockers
ecr helps users to save monitor and
deploy docker and the containers
later sagemaker sets up a cluster for
the input data
trains it and stores it in the amazon s3
itself so this is done by the sagemaker
itself
after that you need to deploy it so
suppose you want to predict limited data
at a time
you use amazon sage maker hosting
services for that okay
but if you want to get prediction for an
entire data set
prefer using amazon sage maker batch
transform
now the last step that is to deploy
the model so once tuning is done models
can be deployed to sagemaker endpoints
and in the end point real time
prediction is performed so you would
have some
data which you would reserve and
validate your model whether it is
working correctly or not
now evaluate your model and determine
whether you have achieved your business
goals
now the other aspect is how we can train
a model with aws stage maker
so this is basically a flow diagram
which shows you how to train a model
with the aws sagemaker
and here we have used couple of services
of an aws
to get that done so model training in
aws sage maker is done on
machine learning compute instances and
here
we can see there are two machine
learning compute instances used as
helper code
and the training code along with that we
are using 2s3 buckets and the ecr for
the container registry
let's look into what are the ways to
train the model as per the slides
so below are the following requirements
to train a model so here in the diagram
you can see these are the following
requirements
to train a model the url of an amazon s3
bucket
where the training data is stored that
is mentioned
the compute resources on machine
learning compute instances
so these are all your machine learning
compute instances
then the url of an amazon s3 bucket
where the output will be stored
and the path of aws elastic container
registry
where the code data is safe the
inference code image lies in the
elastic container registry now what are
these calls these are called as
the training jobs now when a user trains
a model in amazon sage maker he she
creates a training job so we need to
first create a training job
and then the input data is fetched from
the specified amazon s3 bucket
once the training job is built amazon
sage maker launches the ml compute
instances so these compute instances
will be launched once the
training job is built then it trains the
model with the training code and the
data set
and it shows the output and model rt
graphs in the aws s3 bucket so this is
done
automatically now here the helper code
performs a task when the training code
fails the interference code which is in
the elastic container registry
consists of multiple linear sequence
containers
that process the request for inference
on data
the ec2 container industry is a
container registry that helps users to
save monitor and deploy container images
whereas container images are the ready
applications
once the data is trained the output is
stored in the specified
amazon s3 bucket so here you can see the
output will be stored here
to prevent your algorithm being deleted
save the data in amazon sagemaker
critical system
which can process you on your ml compute
instances
now how to validate a model let's look
into it so you can evaluate your model
using offline or using the historical
data
so first thing is that you can do the
offline testing to validate a model
you can do an online testing with the
live data so if you have a live data
coming or
real real-time streams coming you can
validate a model from there itself
you can validate using a hold out set
and also you can validate using the
k-fold
validation now use historical data to
send requests to the model
through the jupiter notebook in amazon
sagemaker for the evaluation
online testing with livedata deploys
multiple models
into the endpoints of amazon sagemaker
and directs live traffic
to the model for validation validating
using a holdout set
is part of the data is set aside where
which is called holdout set so the part
of the data is left
which is basically called as the holdout
set
this data is not used for the model
training so later when the model is
trained
with the remaining input data and
generalize the data based on what is
learnt initially so whatever the data
which is left out
will be used for validating a model
because we have not used that data
while training a model the k-fold
validation
is the input data is split into two
parts
one part is called k which is the
validation data
for testing the model and the other part
is k minus 1
which is used as a training data now
based on the input data the machine
learning model evaluates
the final output now
the companies that are using aws
sagemaker one is the adp
so you must be knowing about adb zlando
dow jones which is on the stock market
proquest and the intuit
now let's look into the demo that how we
can actually
run the aws sagemaker so we'll use the r
algorithm
and then package the algorithm as a
container for
building training and deploying a model
we are going to use the jupiter notebook
for that
for model building for model training
for model deployment
and the code for the demo is in the
below link so you can see here
that from this link you can get the code
for the demo
let's try to do a demo on the aws
now i would be using a link which is
provided by amazon to build train and
deploy the machine learning model on the
sagemaker as you can see on my screen
and in this tutorial you would have some
steps where you can put those steps and
the code
python codes into your aws sagemaker
jupiter lab
so in this tutorial you will learn how
to use amazon sagemaker to build train
and deploy a machine learning model
and for that we will use the popular xt
boost ml algorithm for this exercise so
first of all what you need to do is you
have to go to the aws console and there
you have to create a notebook instance
so in this tutorial you will be creating
a notebook instance
you will prepare the data train the
model to learn from the data
deploy the model evaluate your ml models
performance and once all those
activities are done
then we will see how we can actually
remove all the resources in order to
prevent the extra costing now the first
step is we have to enter to the amazon
sagemaker console
so here you can see i'm already logged
in into the sagemaker console
you can click on the services search for
the sagemaker here
and here you get the amazon sage maker
service
now the next step is that we have to
create a notebook instance
so we will select the notebook instance
from the sagemaker service
and then after the notebook instance is
selected we
put a name to our instance and we'll
create a new
im role for that so let's wait for the
sage maker studio to open
so here you can see the studio is open
and
you just have to click on the notebook
instances
and here you have to create a notebook
instance so here you can see couple of
notebook instances have already been
created
one of them is in service so this is the
notebook instance that we are going to
use for
creating the demo model i'll show you
how you can create a notebook instance
you just have to click on
create notebook instance button and put
your notebook instance
name so you can put something like demo
dash
sage maker 987 or we can put it as
model we'll go with notebook instance
type as default which is mlt2.medium
and in the permission and encryptions
under the im role
we'll click on create a new im role
now why we are creating a new im role so
that we can allow the sage maker
to access any s3 bucket that has been
created on our account
just click on create a role and here you
would see
that the new im role will be created
with the set of permissions
then rest of the things will keep it as
default
and then you just have to click on
create a notebook instance the notebook
instance creation takes some time so you
just have to wait for a couple of
minutes to get that in service
we already have one of the notebook
instance that has been created
so we will be using that to create
a demo now going back to the steps
so these are the steps that we have
already performed
now once the notebook instance is
created then we have to prepare the data
so in this step we will be
using the sagemaker notebook instance to
pre-process the data
that would require to train the machine
learning
model and for that we would be opening
up
the jupyter notebook and then we have to
select an environment a kernel
environment in the jupiter notebook that
would be
conda underscore python 3.
so let's follow these steps go back to
the sage maker
click on the notebook instances
select the running notebook instance and
here
you would select the open jupyter lab
now here you would see that the sage
maker would try to open up
the jupiter notepad
and we would be performing all our
inputs into that
jupiter notebook and executing the
results there itself so just wait for
the notebook to open
now here you can see the jupiter lab
notebook has been open
so i would be selecting one of the
notebook that has been created
so this one so likewise you can create
your own notebook also
how you can do that first of all let me
select the kernel environment so i would
be selecting corner
underscore python 3 and just click on
select
so how you can create your own notebook
just have to click on file
click on new and here you can select the
notebook
just name your notebook select the
environment
conda underscore python 3 to run this
demo
so i have my notebook open so in the
tabs i would be
putting up the python codes and i would
be executing those codes to get the
output directly
so the next step is to prepare the data
train the ml model and deploy it
we will need to import some libraries
and define a few environment variables
in the jupyter notebook environment
so i would be copying this code which
you can see that would try to import
numpy pandas
these are all required to run the python
syntax so just
copy this code
and paste it into your notebook
right so once you do that execute your
code
and here you can see that you get the
output
which is that it has imported
all the necessary libraries that have
been defined in the code
now the next step is we would create an
s3 bucket
into the s3 service and for that you
have to copy this python code
just that you have to edit it so you
have to specify
this bucket name that you want to get
created so here i would
provide the bucket name which should be
unique
should not overlap so something like
sage maker dash
demo
is the name that i have selected for the
bucket and now you have to
execute that code it says that the s3
bucket has been created successfully
with the name sage maker dash demo 9876
so this is something which you can
verify so you can go to the s3
service and there you can verify whether
the bucket has been created or not
now the next task is that we need to
download
the data to the aws sagemaker instance
and load it into the data frame and for
that
we have to follow this url so from this
url
which is build train deploy machine
learning model
would have a data in the form of bank
underscore clean.csv
and this will be deployed onto our
sagemaker instance
we'll copy this code and
paste it here and execute the code
so it says that it has successfully
downloaded
bank underscore clean.csv which is which
has the data inside it
and that has been loaded into the
sagemaker
data frame successfully now we have a
data to
build and train our machine learning
model
so what we are going to do we are going
to shuffle the data and we are going to
split it
one into the training data set and the
other one into
test data set so for the training data
set we are going to use 70
of the customers that are listed in the
csv file
and 30 of the customers in the csv file
data we will be using it as a test data
to train the model
so we will copy the following code into
a new code cell
and then we are going to run that code
cell
so i'll just copy it for training the
data so that we can segregate
the data model 70 for building the model
and
30 for testing the data
so click on
run the execution and here you can see
that we got the output
successfully
now we have to train the model from that
data so how we are going to train that
model and for that
we'll use sagemaker prebuilt xgboost
model which is an algorithm
so you will need to reformat the header
and first column of the training data
and load the data from the
s3 bucket so what i'll do is i'll copy
this syntax
and paste it in the note cell
so it has the trained data it would
train
the model click on run execution
now it is changing the s3 input class
which will be
renamed to training input because now we
are training the model
with the training data so we just have
to wait for some time
till it gets executed completely
now the next thing is that we need to
set up the amazon sagemaker session
to create an instance of the xg boost
model
so here we are going to create this
sagemaker session say
we are going to create an instance of
the xt boost
model which is an estimator so just
copy that copy that code
and paste it here
executed and here you can see that
it will start it has basically changed
the parameter image name to the image
underscore uri
in this sage maker python sdk v2
now we'll follow the next step that is
with the data loaded in the xt boost
estimator
we'll set up train the model using
gradient
optimization and
we'll copy the following code and that
would actually start
the training of the model
so copy this code
and this would actually start
training the model using our input data
that we have reserved 70
of that data that we have reserved for
training the model
so just copy that
again initiate the execution and it will
start the training job now we'll deploy
the model
and for that i would copy the deploy
code
put that in the cell
and execute it so
it says parameter image will be renamed
to image uri
and using already existing models so xd
boost was deployed already
if you have not done that if you're
doing it the first time so it will
initiate another xt boost instance so
where you can find your xt boost
endpoints created
you just have to scroll down and here
under the
inference click on the end points and
you should find
the xg boost endpoints defined here so
here you can see
that today i have created one xd boost
endpoint and that is now in process of
creating so just refresh it
so it is still created it is going to
take some time
to get that in service now our endpoint
is
in service state so now we can use it so
going forward with the next steps we
will try to predict whether the customer
in the test data enroll for the bank
product or not
for that we are going to copy this code
put that in the jupiter
cell function and execute it
so here it gives you the output that it
has
actually evaluated and the same output
we got
in the screenshot of the demo as well
now we are going to evaluate the model
performance
so what we are going to do we are going
to get the prediction done
so based on the prediction we can
conclude that you predicted a customer
that will enroll for a certificate of
deposit accurately for 90
of the customers in the test data with
the precision of 65 percent
for enrolled and 90 which are which
haven't
enrolled for it so for that we are going
to copy
this code
and execute it here in the cell
so if it is predicted correctly that
means our model is
working absolutely fine so here you can
say the overall
classification rate is 89.5 percent and
there is the accurate prediction that
has
been made by the model and that's what
the output we can see here
in the screenshot of a model so that
means our model is absolutely working
fine it has been
built deployed and trained correctly
now the next thing is that once you are
done with that you terminate your
resources
and for that you just have to copy uh
this code and put that in the cell
function so that
the additional resources and the
endpoints and the buckets that have been
created
by the jupiter notepad should be
terminated so that you would not be
incurred with the
extra costing so just execute it
and here you would see that it has tried
to it would
try to terminate all the additional
resources that we have created from the
jupyter notebook
that was with respect to how we can use
the aws sagemaker demo guys watch out
for more space
with respect to the upcoming videos
thank you bye for now
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here